again to a snowy road trip a Subaru is
the perfect vehicle for Colder Weather
driving JC Fernandez stopped by Subaru
of Las Vegas the sponsors of this
segment to learn more
[Music]
hi
oh
there it is
[Music]
Hey JC did you just fall asleep yes I
did I was dreaming about whipping around
in the snow in the super while back oh
that sounds fun these cars are amazing
oh well you're from Hawaii originally
what do you like to do when it comes to
the outdoors and Subarus well Lee Canyon
come on I mean you know we have a
partnership with Lee Cannon Subaru does
and if you go up there in a Subaru you
get to park in a special parking spot oh
my gosh that's amazing it's the
wintertime colder weather is here
shouldn't it be something we should be
doing to kind of winterize our car
absolutely whenever winter comes or
summer comes you really need to pay
attention to your car can you show us
some of the details let's take a look
Subaru is famous for their boxer engines
this is our turbocharged version in the
winter you want to make sure that you
you have a battery that's going to work
for you that your fluids are all topped
up and they're in good condition it's
important all these things so you have
no surprises on the road so this is
something you can check at your house
but I would rather keep it and leave it
up to the pros like yourself yeah
because we want to go and do it once
over on the whole car in case something
else going wrong and tires are important
too oh my goodness they are tire
pressures drop during the cold months so
that's important that we get those tire
pressures up to where they need to be
and we need to check to make sure that
the tires are not dry rotted what makes
Subaru the perfect car for driving in
these winter conditions Subaru
symmetrical all-wheel drive it is the
best that and the factory there's plenty
of room here you can put your snowboard
in there put your skis put your sleds
and head on a nice road trip with the
family for the winter we have all those
accessories available too well super
Road Burton you guys are always giving
back to Las Vegas I'm sure this time of
year is extra special for you one of our
favorite events the Subaru share the
love event this is the 15th Year we're
doing this four National Charities uh
are going to receive funds after this
sale is over and two Hometown Charities
and it's really a great thing 250 for
every new car sold or leased during this
period go to these Charities and the
people buying the car actually gets to
make the selection of who receives the
funds so you're buying a car for a good
cause yes Burton thank you so much happy
holidays my friend thank you
I've had it
confidence is
and the Oscar nomination goes to JC
Fernandez for pretending to drive a car
in the snow Finley Subaru of Las Vegas
is located at 6455 Roy horn way you can
call them at that phone number
702495-2100 they have a really good
offer right now 3.9 financing for
well-qualified buyers for up to 48
months on select 2022 and 2023 models
I'm having questions